altogether there have been two kingdoms
of hungary the first one lasted for
almost a thousand years and formed an
important part of the habsburg domain
and the second one is famous for not
actually having a king it did have a
region whose job it was to find a king
and there were many people who were
happy to take the job but notably he
never did this and the kingdom of
hungary remained without a monarch until
its disillusion in 1946 so the kingdom
of hungary was reborn after the collapse
of the austro-hungarian empire in world
war one hungary was briefly declared a
republic broke down into civil war was
declared a soviet republic invaded
romania lost and broke down into civil
war again before returning to a
democratic republic where it would
stably remain and never mind there was
another civil war this eventually saw
meek los horthy a very well-respected
admiral named regent of the landlocked
country at the head of a conservative
coalition and horthy then reluctantly
signed hungary's surrender document but
this wasn't until after some of the
members of his government had asked if
britain was willing to install one of
its princes to the hungarian throne and
this was offered on the condition that
hungary loses less land but
unsurprisingly britain said no so as
regent it was horthy's job to make
himself redundant by replacing himself
with the king this seemed like a pretty
easy job at the time since the last king
of hungary charles habsburg was still
active and living in switzerland but not
for long though since he soon snuck into
hungary to relieve horthy of his job
horthy refused though because france and
the little anton surrounding hungary had
made it clear that a habsburg on the
throne meant war charles bided his time
and later in 1920 he returned to
budapest with an army of volunteers he
had promised this army that his return
would be greeted with cheers but when it
was greeted with bullets his army mostly
gave up and he was forced to leave the
country forever more with the last
habsburg claimant gone that meant that
horthy needed to pick another king so
horthy's initial plan was to wait for
hungary in the international landscape
to stabilize before choosing a new
monarch but as you'll know no king was
ever chosen so why not well there were
several candidates that held some
support for taking the throne the first
and most prominent was king ferdinand of
romania the reason that ferdinand had
some support was that romania now
controlled transylvania which was
majority hungarian and there was a
belief that having ferdinand to be king
of both would protect the rights of
hungarians in romania and it also likely
meant that hungary could shake off some
of the worst terms of its surrender the
answer was an obvious no since a year
previous ferdinand's armies had invaded
and occupied much of hungary and all of
the other candidates were minor princes
from basically every european royal
family and very few of them had much
support which left one last potential
candidate horthy himself there were some
who wanted a hungarian royal family and
since horthy was so well respected he
would do horthy of course would never
accept the title for two reasons the
first was that his allies supported him
as a region who would one day restore a
monarchy but not as a monarch himself
and second by becoming king he would
become a constitutional monarch which
would mean he would wield less power
than he did as a regent which he didn't
want because everybody loves power and
with that he simply remained as regent
with dictatorial powers which he could
prop up with the one day soon i totally
promised any minute now guarantee that
he would restore the crown of saint
stephen and with that and hungary's
eventual loss in world war ii its days
of being ruled by a monarch were over i
hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette kelly moneymaker sky
chappelle caution wolf jerry lamdin
jordan longley adam stalter marcus
arsenault wyan hockey spencer lightfoot
rod d martin words about books podcast
captain cydog gustav swan marvin castle
common yoon winston k wood bugilly
wiggly daniel to be in miss izzette
matthew shipley aaron the white corey
turner the mcwhopper alex schwinn
anthony beckett coppertone maggie
patzkowski schwennin spinning three
plates and charles the first